l'univers n'a pas toujours été tel que
nous le connaissons aujourd'hui
à l'origine il y avait le fco smic
un concentré de masse atomique qui
explosa après avoir atteint la limite de
la densité
il y à 15 milliards d'années et projeta
ces fragments à travers l'espace
certains de ces fragments sont restés
incandescent et ont formé les étoiles
d'autres se sont refroidies et ont formé
les planètes et les météorites ses
éclats voyageant dans l'espace ont fini
par former le nombre inimaginable de 10
puissance 11 galaxy qui forment
l'univers l'univers et 6,6 dantesque que
notre galaxie la voie lactée déjà
immense puisqu'elle contient 234
milliards de systèmes solaires en plus
d'une autre n'est qu'une goutte d'eau
dans cet énorme océans
il y a environ 5 milliards d'années dans
un agglomérat de météorites et rentrent
dans l'espace la présence de radiations
ultraviolettes permet l'apparition des
glucides molécule essentielle pour les
fonctions reproductives quand ces
météorites et leurs glucides entre en
collision avec des planètes ou le
carbone et l'eau liquide sont déjà
présents la vie apparaît c'est ainsi que
des formes de vie naissent sur certaines
planètes de la voie lactée et
probablement sur d'innombrables planète
d'autres galaxies il y a environ un
million d'années la voie lactée s'anime
des êtres semblables aux humains mais
mesurant deux fois leur taille les
belliqueux hanouna qui ce qui prédomine
sur une planète orbitant autour de
l'étoile nemesis acquiert d'une
technologie si avancé qu'ils peuvent
explorer l'espace
ils parviennent même à pénétrer le
système solaire colonise en mars eni bis
rue pour en faire des stations spatiales
ni bis rue est une planète qui m'est
3600 ans pour effectuer son parcours
autour du soleil
au commencement
lorsqu'elle fut attirée par les forces
gravitationnelles de notre système
solaire ni béru entra en collision avec
la planète chjama et la cassa en deux
générant la terre et la lune son orbite
s'est maintenant stabilisé mais dans le
passé à chaque fois que nibiru
s'approcher de la terre elle causait un
désastre
ces passages successifs provoquèrent les
glaciations la fossilisation de forêts
entières et la disparition d'animaux
énorme tels que les dinosaures
il y à environ 250 milles ans à cause de
son orbite qui l'éloignent du soleil
pendant longtemps ni des rues gel pour
la réchauffer les colonisateurs hanouna
qui crée un effet de serre en ébullition
uranium hélium et or dans son atmosphère
ni les rues restaient cependant trop
pauvre en or l'occasion pour en obtenir
davantage se présente quand le roi
hanouna qui halal ou destituer denis
virus est réfugié sur la terre découvre
qu'il y a de l'or en abondance sur cette
planète
l'inscription suivante se trouvant sur
une tablette sumérienne en témoignent
sur la grande montagne de mars
ils les ont sculpté avec les rayons
l'image d' allah lui que son visage
regarde pour toujours vernis bis rue où
il a régné et vers la terre où il a
découvert l'or
sur mars dans la zone de saint dounia il
y a en effet une formation montagneuse
semblable à un visage humain
les sumériens sont fiables
il y a cinq mille ans il représentait
déjà toutes les planètes de notre
système solaire y compris uranus neptune
et pluton qui pourtant fut redécouverte
il ya peu de temps ce n'est pas un
hasard si le premier salut 1,6 et sur le
disque qui a accompagné en 1977 les sons
américaine voyageurs lancé dans l'espace
pour contacter d'éventuelles
civilisations extraterrestres était en
langue sumérienne
dans le nouveau roi denis les rues à
nous apprend qu'il y a de l'or sur la
terre
il prend la tête d'une expédition
accompagné par ses fils en qui est en
l'île par d'autres membres de la famille
royale et plusieurs centaines de
scientifiques de militaires à nous
débarque au sud de la mésopotamie où il
établit et reed ou qui veut dire maison
loin de la maison
les tablettes sumériennes site les
halles où naquit comme étant ceux qui
sont venu des cieux sur terre
elle raconte que à nous confine à la lui
sur mars et que les hanouna qui commence
la construction des établissements
nécessaire à la mission ayant besoin
d'eau et de glucides
il crée les dden chant d'agriculture et
d'élevage
puis en explorant la terre entière il
découvre d'abondants gisement d'or au
sud de l'afrique
satisfait le roi à nour par et laisse le
commandement de la mission à m lille son
héritier dandy que haine qui dirige les
mines d'or dans l'actuelle zimbabwe
mais les explorateurs hanouna qui
utilisés pour la dure tâche des
excavations d'or refuse bientôt de
travailler dans la bible écrite des
millénaires plus tard et qui reprend les
récits sumériens les hanouna qui sont
appelés elohim et cette rébellion est
représentée par les anges désobéissant
aux ordres de dieu en ce temps là des
troupes beau d'homo erectus vivent au
sud de l'afrique
en les observant un qui réalise que ces
primates sont adaptés à creuser la terre
ils capturent donc une femelle erectus
et l'amène à l île chef de la mission
celui ci donne l'autorisation
d'effectuer des expérimentations et le
groupe médical hanouna qui manipulent
génétiquement un ovule de cette femelle
le greffant à l'adn denis sûrs sags
épouse de haine qui c'est ainsi qu'il y
a environ deux cent mille ans n'est un
hybride stérile
mal fort physiquement et intelligent les
hanouna qui l'appelle lulu et en clown
un millier qu'il transporte en grande
partie en afrique
créé pour obéir et travailler l'élu lui
intègre des concepts inexistant dans la
nature
celui de dieu en reconnaissant des
capacités supérieures des hanouna qui
est celui de l'immortalité tirer du fait
qu'ils ne peuvent jamais constaté la
mort des ânes ou laqué puisque leur
espérance de vie dépasse de milliers
d'années terrestre excité et amusé par
cette expérimentation end il ordonne à
ses médecins de réaliser de nouveau être
en mélangeant l'adn du lulu à celui
d'autres animaux
c'est ainsi qu'ils obtiennent le pan
un hêtre moitié lui et moitié chèvre
auquel n'est hanouna qui enseigne à
jouer de la flûte
busnes jument n'est le centaure moitié
lui et moitié cheval auquel il enseigne
lusage de l'arc
puis il crée toutes les créatures
animales est décrite dans les
mythologies
l'amusement se termine lorsque ces
hybrides s'éteignent ne vivent que cent
ans tout comme l'élu lui les médecins
clooney en continu mais en nombre
insuffisant
les travaux traînait un qui comprit
alors qu'il fallait à lulu fertile à à
procréer sans plus passer par les
laboratoires n lille n'étaient pas
d'accord sur ce point
ils craignaient une croissance
incontrôlable de ces êtres qui aurait pu
se rebeller faisant ainsi échouer leur
mission
enki rétorqua qu'avec ce nombre limité
de lulu à disposition la mission allait
sûrement échoué alors contre son gré
elle il finit par approuver la
fertilisation du lulu et l'on produisit
l'adamant l'homo sapiens le progéniteurs
de l'homme actuel créé à l'image et à
l'égal des halles où naquit c'était un
lulu améliorer effet coup qui vivait 300
en costaud et de deux mètres de haut de
l'état de pacific cueilleurs de et de
végétaux ce primate bassa'a l'état
d'homme le plus féroce ceux des
chasseurs terrestre cette idée que la
dame a puisse être dangereux diviser
encore les hanouna qui n lille était
soutenue par la famille royale et les
militaires qui voulaient tous éliminés
les adama en faveur des lulus plus
contrôlable enki appuyé par les
scientifiques considéraient que les
adama bien instruits et est une
ressource importante pour les hanouna
qui est que dans le futur ce serait à
ces êtres humains qu'ils reviendraient
de gouverner la terre les adama vont
dont succéder au lulu dans l'éden pour
le travail des champs et une grande
partie sera transportée au zimbabwe dans
les mines d'or
un problème se pose en afrique lorsque
enki en grosse deux femelles humaine et
que celle ci met au monde des fils quand
elle lit la france il devient fou de
rage c'est un opprobre pour lui autant
que l'union sexuelle d'un homme avec un
animal l'est aujourd'hui
il accuse les femelles humaines de péché
originel et ne souhaitant pas que ce
problème surgit sahiri il ordonne de
chasser les êtres humains de l'éden dans
la bible c'est le renvoi du paradis
terrain
en afrique
enki de chasse personne bien au
contraire ils enseignent des
connaissances supérieur à certains
humains pour en faire les premiers rois
le reste des hommes eux doivent creuser
enki considéré comme un dieu confère le
titre de prêtres à des initiés et
instaure la première religion sa règle l
obéissance totale
la menace ultime est la mort l'homme est
donc contraint de servir ce dieu un
citoyen pire encore ce concept du
pouvoir absolu est adoptée par les rois
qui exploite à leur tour leur assujettis
avec violence
il y a environ cent mille ans le roi à
nous leurs ailes lille n'a pas de temps
à perdre s'il veut conserver le trône
les hanouna qui sont sans scrupules et
les prétendants ne manquent pas il
déclare dont la fin de la mission
sa priorité est désormais que tout se
retourne sur ni bis rue pour défendre
son trône
enki n'étant qu'un fils engendrée par
une concubine sait qu'il ne pourra pas
accéder au trône il refuse de partir
estimant avoir déjà son propre trône en
afrique n lille se fâche
il leur donne aux hanouna qui a signé au
port spatial de l'île de pâques les
fameux moai le garder heynckes sous
contrôle puis lui et sa suite
quitte la terre enki ne sachant pas quoi
faire de tout cet or abandonné le donne
en cadeau aux hommes les plus fidèles
c'est l'âge d'or et il y en a en
abondance à cette époque
il y a environ 50 mille ans enki et sa
cour quitte le zimbabwe pourrait rire
peut se déplacent à bord de leurs
machines volantes et son suivi sur terre
par les rois les plus fidèles et leurs
peuples
c'est la première grande migration
humaine allant de l'afrique au moyen
orient
en remerciement enki donne à toute fille
de roi
l'un de ses fils comme époux et de ses
union naissent des mortels exceptionnel
les dieux héros
cependant à erie du 7 e concentration
d'anaky et de dieu héros tous guerrier
risquant de se transformer en conflit
enki envoie les lieux héros conquérir la
terre entière déjà occupé par les
descendants des renvoyé du paradis
terrestre
les dieux héros partent dont et certains
vont occuper l'egypte et la palestine
d'autres envahissent le continent
européen et élimine les hommes de
néandertal d'autres s'établissent à
malte et en sardaigne en faisant des
cités écoles pour initier d'autres
s'installent sur les terres jadis
émerger de l'océan atlantique et fonde
la puissante atlantide et d'autres
encore arrivent jusqu'en chine et en
inde
les dieux et héros équipe leur
territoire de base pour le lancement de
missiles de gigantesques construction en
pierres ou garder leur armes nucléaires
et des normes phare pyramidaux visible
du cosmos c'est ainsi qu'apparaît
simultanément en différentes parties du
monde
le même type de construction et de
culture à la mort des dieux héros leur
troll passe aux descendants engendré
avec des humaine formant les premières
postérité royal
il y a environ 12 mille ans la flotte
spatiale de haine lille devenu roi de
nibiru revient sur la terre pour
éliminer ces êtres humains qu'ils
avaient contre son gré autorisé à voir
le jour et qui tente de communiquer avec
son frère la réponse est un rayon
destructeur entre le maroc et l'espagne
actuelle dans un grondement terrifiant
la terre qu'il n'y ait l'afrique à
l'europe se désintègre dans l'est
l'océan atlantique s'engouffre comme une
furie par le détroit de gibraltar
à peine créée telle une énorme canonnade
doute les flots pénerf dans la
méditerranée détruisant les écoles
d'initiation à malte et en sardaigne il
submerge l'italie la séparant de la
tunisie ils n'ont de la plaine grecque y
créant des îles puis pénètre entre la
bulgarie et la turquie pour former la
mer noire enfin des vagues au 200 m
eric balayant tout sur leur passage
qualifié de déluge universel dans la
bible ce désastre ne touche en réalité
que la zone allant de la méditerranée à
la mésopotamie
enki averti le roi souverain le noé
biblique qui construit une grande barque
où il se réfugie avec sa famille et ses
animaux d'autres survivants provenant
des terres désormais submergées par la
mer noire vont s'installer non loin des
rives du où il fonde sûrs constituant le
peuple des sumériens ils ne savent pas
qu'ils sont près d'une base hanouna qui
n lille aperçoit ces quelques survivants
humains
mais quand on qui se jettent à ses pieds
il triomphe et se satisfait de la
situation
cependant il n'est pas revenu dans le
système solaire uniquement pour punir
enki et les humains il doit évacuer mars
devenus inutiles
il repart donc avec son escroc
entre-temps l'arche s'est enlisé dans
l'actuelle arménie noé sa famille
sortent alors et se regroupent dans les
premières agglomérations urbaines
ils cultivent la terre élèvent des
animaux et vivent en harmonie avec la
nature
oubliant leur origine extraterrestre
les organistes une société sans
hiérarchie et sans discrimination
sexuelle avec comme règle le cadeau pour
entreprendre les échanges en mésopotamie
les sumériens découvrent leurs voisins
hanouna qui est les adore comme des
dieux les hanouna qui peut se flattant
d'être considérés comme des divinités
s'amuse à exposer leur savoir à ces
petits hommes à la tête noire
dès lors les sumériens invente
l'écriture en imprimant sur des
tablettes en argile des caractères
cunéiformes représentant les expressions
phonétique de la parole il invente
l'école pour l'instruction des
accomplissent des calculs compliqués en
ingéniérie se montrant capable de
résoudre des équations algébriques de
troisième degré ils connaissent le
système solaire et invente le premier
calendrier divisant le jour 24 heures et
leur en 60 minutes
de leur côté les hanouna qui ambitionne
de se partager la tête
le fils de enki marre du sou mais les
gens de la tunisie jusqu'au soudan et
constitue le peuple des égyptiens son
domaine comprend tu les pyramides jadis
construite par les dieux héros tout
comme le prince un énorme lyon en bière
que marzouki fait modifier pour lui
donner le visage de son fils nabeul
mais marc duc et bientôt chasse et
d'égypte et revient en mésopotamie où il
bâtit babylone trois frères hanouna qui
dan rama et vira occupe la scandinavie
qu'ils abandonnent pour chercher un
climat plus tempéré quand dan occupe la
sardaigne pour s'établir plus tard en
italie où il constitue le peuple des
étrusques rama arrive en inde mais une
race noire très évolués l'obligent à se
replier en anatolie
où il constitue le peuple indo-européen
le troisième frère vira se dirige vers
le détroit de béring et rentrer en
amérique longe la côte et arrive en
colombie où il fonde la civilisation
andine lane où naquit ou en appeler
l'empereur jaune occupe la plaine de
pékin et envahit les peuples voisins
établissant l'ancienne chine
la nina qui a way occupe la palestine et
sally a marre du que pour détruire
sodome et gomorrhe qui refusent de se
rendre les murs vitrifiés de ces villes
affichent encore une radioactivité
typique des explosions nucléaires y
avait avait un ami humain
abraham et cette amitié les amène à un
pacte d'alliance yahvé premier à abraham
et à sa progéniture qu'il leur donnera
le pays de cana en contrepartie abraham
jurent de se rendre un culte à y avait
en tant que dieu unis et de se faire
circoncire lui et ses enfants mal pour
se distinguer des hommes des autres
factions dans le récit biblique
l'un des fils d'abraham ismaël est
l'ancêtre des tribus islamique
tandis que le petit fils d'abraham jacob
est l'ancêtre des tribus d'israël
il y a environ 5000 ans une révolte
éclate sur nous verrons
el nil et sur mars et la quittes de si
mauvaise humeur qu'il arrive sur ni
virus et comme et temps d'inéquité que
sa propre famille royale le contraint à
l'exil
c'est qui qui est alors appelée
d'urgence sur 10 bis rue comme héritier
du trône lui qui souhaite laisser aux
hommes la gestion de la terre a pas de
les annuler acquis répartis dans le
monde en leur promettant que s'il le
suivent il partagera avec eux le pouvoir
sur ni virus
c'est ainsi qu'il y a environ 5000 ans
les hanouna qui abandonne la terre
les annotations sumérienne se termine
d'ailleurs à cette date
à cette même date la préhistoire
s'achève et l'histoire débute
pourtant en 1939 à ninive
si nous n'avions pas découvert ces
milliers de tablettes sumériennes qui
cite nos ancêtres comme étant le produit
d'une manipulation génétique entre un
primate est un extraterrestre nous
n'aurions pas eu grand chose sur
l'origine de la race humaine
si ce que les sumériens ont écrit est
vrai cela explique le manque de pièces
prouvant l'évolution darwinienne de
l'homme et ses énormes oeuvre en pierres
que notre technologie d'aujourd'hui ne
peut égaler si cela n'est pas vrai très
vives félicitations à la fantaisie de
ces sumériens qu' il y a cinq mille ans
ont inventé cette histoire fantastique